look guys it's just Dane and today we're
checking out the new smart battery cases
that Apple announced and this kind of
caught me off guard actually because I
really didn't expect this it's not that
surprising because they've had these in
the past where the fact that they have
this free iPhone 10's Matt is kind of
crazy because this is huge
I've seen a bunch of names online
talking about how thick these cases are
but the reason that I'm mostly surprised
by this is this is something that I
absolutely do not need at all like I
don't need this if you had iPhone 10's
max or even the 10s I get such
incredible battery life with this and
I'm on my phone constantly all that
being said I really don't ever leave the
house without having an external battery
charger with me because there is always
that small voice in the back of my mind
that says what if your phone dies what
if somebody else's phone dies so I kind
of always liked to be very very prepared
I also always have a ton of other
gadgets with me so it is nice to have a
battery pack that will be able to charge
like my GoPro or my camera but that's
not what this videos about this video is
about these guys and checking them out
because I wanted to see for myself what
they looked like what a day would look
like using this would it kind of put my
mind at a little bit more ease because
with this extra added battery I feel
like I probably would really not even
think about it at all it'll just extend
this already really great battery life
that I've had with this so far even
further these are pretty expensive I've
really never had any of the other smart
cases in the past but this is not even
$30 for just one with that you could
definitely buy an external battery
charger that would charge multiple
devices so really I guess it depends do
you want to have this battery built-in
or even have something that you could
just have sometimes well that was a
really uneventful unboxing here's the
white one oh holy crap this thing is
huge this is massive
get out of your home Wow
that's that's thick there we go that's
unboxing number two all right I'm glad
to give these instructions on how to
install it because I don't know I don't
think it's something I'd be able to
figure out maybe you have questions I
don't know
I mean milliamps are you giving us we're
trying to read it I'm so old I can't
freaking see thirteen six nine million
so that's actually really that's not
very much like you can get a tiny little
okay like so movie has these new movie
minis that are 10,000 milliamp that are
like super small okay here we go this
for traveling is probably what I would
mostly use this for because when I am on
a plane it's kind of annoying to have to
actually charge your phone but this is
definitely an option it is thick it is
significantly heavier than I thought
that it would be so the smart case did
not come already charge you'd think that
I would have 500 cables laying around
here you would think one would thing so
one of the things that I do like is
you'll be able to see what the charge is
on the smart case and on your phone kind
of like your ear pods it sort of lives
all in that little ecosystem I just
think that if you do have one of these
phones the battery life it's just I
don't think that this is entirely
necessary but if you are the kind of
person who doesn't want to have to carry
around an external battery who doesn't
have access to a charger throughout the
day this could easily be something for
you and honestly I'm such a huge fan of
Apple cases like I love these silicon
cases but the bad part about those is
this sometimes happens I am very
aggressive with my phones that is not
new information so this sometimes
happens I love like the felt interior
and there has not been another case that
I found that I really have liked these
have just in my favorite cases since the
beginning now they definitely don't
protect as well as some of the other
like super protective cases I know I've
done drop tests with like the tech21
cases before and like those actually do
protect your problems like those things
are so crazy and aggressive that it is
like your phone is inside of a tank but
if you want something lightweight and
you want
obviously an Apple logo on it these are
my favorite not a big fan of the leather
ones I do like the leather look but I
feel like again I'm so abusive and they
are a little bit more expensive leather
and I just sometimes don't get along
very well I spill things on it and
that's definitely not something that is
covered under Apple's warranty so I just
definitely prefer the ease so yeah I
guess back to these cases I would love
to know what you guys think because this
is definitely it's I mean it's massive I
mean this phone itself is massive and
most of the times when I'm using the
phone like I actually do prefer using my
tennis and yeah I know just named you
need to have two iPhones obviously I'm
just I'm crazy now how do I get you out
of here that was something that was not
covered in the documentation hey do you
wanna you wanna come out to play
oh my guess I'll start charging this one
get you out oh there we go
that wasn't that bad let's see what you
look like in here got the gold it's just
a credible I forgot how beautiful this
phone is because it's always covered in
a case Oh something else that I noticed
is right that there's a little light to
show you that it is charging so that's
cool in there so I'm gonna be traveling
here pretty soon so I think that this is
probably what I'll go for okay I think
I'll go for this look this is a nice
look so I think that this is the one
that I'm probably gonna go with do you
really like this white case a lot this
looks really nice so really to sum up
like I said I don't entirely think that
this is necessary but if you are a fan
of battery packs I just love the look of
this one I would love to know what you
guys think in the comments below and
what is one thing that you wish that
Apple would make as an accessory for
your iPhone like it can be anything like
do you want to have a selfie flying
drone case like let's think
super super crazy I will see you guys in
my next video also let me know if
there's any other things that you would
like me to cover
and I will see you in my next video so
bye
[Music]